Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 13. Das letzte Interview vom Chaos Communication Congress in Berlin 2005. Wir werden uns unterhalten mit Jacob Appelbaum und auch in diesem Fall handelt es sich wieder um ein englisches Interview. Das ist dann wohl die letzte dieser Sonderserie vom Kongress, der Kongress ist heute vorbei. Vier Tage großartiger Erlebnisse, die alle erst noch mal verarbeitet werden sollen, auch hier im Express, am Mikrofon Tim Pritlove. Wir wechseln wieder in Englisch. Wir wechseln wieder in Englisch, weil wir schon ganze Nacht reden. Und wir enden diesen Tag mit diesem Interview und sagen Hallo zu Jacob. Einfach in Kontakt bekommen, durch Inset-Messagen, ein bisschen E-Mail. Aber du hast es dieses Jahr gemacht. Inzwischen gab es viele persönliche Erfahrungen an deinem Seite. Vielleicht können wir uns einfach in deine persönliche Technik-Historie befinden.
Ich glaube, das erste Mal, dass ich in die Computer-Historie bin, war als ich in der Schulzeit in Oregon Trail hackte. Einige der anderen Kinder hatten Word-Games mit Passwörtern, die man während der Mittagszeit gewinnen konnte. Was ist Oregon Trail? So der Apple Computer war deine erste Maschine?
Dein Thema war die Disk-Engreifung, Technologien für Operationssysteme, oder?
Ja, es war eine Diskussion über verschiedene Disk-Engreifungsmethoden. Wir hatten FreeBSD, OpenBSD, NetBSD, Mac OS X und Linux und verschiedene Veranstaltungen, die verschiedene Probleme lösen. Ja, eine Sache, die wirklich toll ist, bei dem Kongress, denke ich, ist, dass ich in der Familie Apple-Developer in der Hand habe, bevor ich sie für ein paar Fehler auf dem Computer in der Hand hatte. Aber dann habe ich ein bisschen über andere Systeme gesprochen, wie viele OpenBSD-Developer hier sind, und dann auch, wie viele NetBSD-Developer, und dann hat eine der Leute, die irgendwie auf diesem Diskrypto gearbeitet, nachher zu mir gesprochen und der Typ, der das Rubber-Hose-File-System geschrieben hat, und ich glaube, er ist ein sehr guter Typ, ich bin mit vielen der Dinge, die du gesagt hast, nicht mit der Frage, was du gesagt hast, ich glaube, das Rubber-Hose-File-System hat einige gute Nutzungen, aber es war einfach toll, weil ich hier diesen Ruf geben kann, und die Frage und Antwort, diese Leute, die das Software geschrieben haben, die über die Threat Modelle gedacht haben, es ist wirklich toll, da wirklich alle Leute da sind, die diese Dinge machen, Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass ich diese Dinge mache. Das ist sehr anders als andere Konferenzen. Also Leute, die ihre eigenen Kameras bauen, Leute, die Pinhole-Kameras aus digitalen Kameras bauen, Fotografie-Hackern, die Leute, die auf den Filesystemen arbeiten, oder Filesystem-Hackern, die Krypto-Hackern, für die Kryptofilesysteme. Ich denke, wenn ich mich in vielen Fällen als sozialer Menschen-Hacker bezeichnen würde, dann würde ich herausfinden, wie es bei der Infalle in Irak, in Houston oder New Orleans, nach Katrina, die Systeme, die in der Lage waren, und die mit diesen Systemen gearbeitet haben, und gegen diese Systeme in einer Weise, die nötig wäre, um Dinge zu erreichen. Ich komme aus einer Stadt in Kalifornien, in den Freien Staaten Amerikaner. Ich verpende jetzt die meiste Zeit in San Francisco, wenn ich nicht reise. Ich reise jetzt auch viel, ich lebe in Toronto, und die letzten paar Monate habe ich in Europa, in Viennland, in London, in Brussels, in Wiesbaden und jetzt in Berlin und bald wieder in Toronto.
Du bist in den letzten 12 Monaten viel unterwegs. Es gab eine bestimmte Grundlage, warum du nicht in den letzten Kongress kommen kannst. Könntest du etwas darüber sagen?
Ich hatte meinen Wunsch geschrieben und alles ging sehr gut, in Bezug auf Planung. Aber sehr schlechte Dinge sind passiert. In meinem ersten Lecture habe ich meine persönlichen Erfahrungen im Reisen gesprochen. Ich bin seit einem Jahr in der Region und habe in den letzten Jahren eine sehr extreme Interpersonale Reise und eine interne Reise, wie auch eine realistische, physische Reise. Ich musste ziemlich viel in die Stadt verlassen, aber auch für sanfte Reise und als ich in die Stadt verlassen habe, kam ich nicht zurück. Ich war im Jahr 2005, ich war in Toronto. Ich war in Toronto für mehrere Monate. Ich habe auch in einigen anderen Orten in der Türkei, in der Praxis und ein paar anderen Orten besucht. Im April bin ich von Istanbul aus nach ein paar Wochen dort und bin in Irak. Also ich flog von Viennland nach Istanbul und ich habe ein paar Wochen in Istanbul geflogen, mich einfach zu einer sehr unterschiedlichen Kultur orientiert. Und also hatte ich einige Freunde in der Türkei und ich habe ein paar Zeit mit den. Türken und habe die Phrases gelernt und habe ein Gefühl für die Menschen in dieser Region. Da war ein witziges, witziges Kurdisch-Jahre, der mit meinem Namen auf dem Ort stand. Natürlich ist das alles in der internationalen Mime-Language, weil wir keine anderen Sprachen in der Mime-Language sprechen, und ich habe ihn gefragt, ob er der Name des Fahrers ist, den ich erwartet habe. Und er sagte, nein, ich bin nicht der Fahrer. Mohammed? Nein, nicht Mohammed. Das erste war, dass es sich für immer dauerte, um zu finden, wo das Gate war. Sie hatten die multifunktionalen Schuhe und waren wie Fußballer. Und ich bin nicht englisch, sondern deutsch und sage, ich bin kein Amerikaner. Ich fragte den Jungen über sein iPod und sagte, was macht ihr hier? Warum kommt ihr hierher? Und dann habe ich sie gefragt, was ihr für den DOD macht. Für die, die zu Hause sind, ist das Bundesamt für Gefecht. Und der Jungen hat gesagt, den DOD? Ich habe die Amerikaner, die in Südwesten und in die Türkei reisen, das bedeutet, dass sie natürlich in den Irak gehen. Der Mann mit dem großen Schlauch, der sich wie ein Fußballer gebaut hat, hat gesagt, mein Name ist Chad und ich bin nicht mit dem DOD, ich bin mit dem GOD. Und also, auf dem Flugzeug, wenn wir fliegen, fliegen wir, erst mal, wir nehmen nicht auf, für einen langen Zeitpunkt. Wir wissen nicht, warum wir auf diesem Flugzeug sind. Es war einfach verrückt, weil sie, als sie das erst angetan haben, sie alle langsam auf dem Rennweg aufhören. Und als das Flugzeug anfing, all die Mitglieder der GOD. Squad, die sich umher hängen, fuhren sich wirklich aufgeregt. Sie konnten nicht mit dem Department of Defense sein, weil sie so festgehalten waren, so offensichtlich nicht zusammen waren. Aber sie hatten weiße Schuhe, also bin ich enttäuscht, dass sie Feds waren. Genau. Und also sind alle anderen Amerikaner auf dem Flugzeug, die sind quasi so, was ist los? Das ist nicht normal, du kannst nicht auf dem Flugzeug rennen. Und natürlich denken sie, das ist Amerika, die Leute auf dem Flugzeug rennen, bald werden Schüsse aufgenommen, oder es ist Terrorismus oder so. Er sagte, du solltest in Istanbul, wenn du auf deiner Weile zurück bist, hier drüben und du kommst vorbei, wir können dir irgendeine Art Levi's bekommen, die du möchtest.
Hattest du Kurdistan, die Kurdistan Region?
Sie waren absolut sicher, dass wir getötet werden. Meine erste Impression war, dass wir, als wir von Diyarbakir nach Zakhau fahren, das erste Mal, dass ich das für mich gemacht habe, dass es eine sehr kleine Stadt war, ich glaube, sie heißt Sipoli, ich vergesse das Name genau, wo der Taxi-Fahrer, der in der ersten Stelle nicht mein Taxi-Fahrer war, es ist so, dass er später der Cousin oder Bruder des Fahrers ist, wir stoppen in der Mitte der Nacht in dieser Stadt, und es gibt einen Raum auf der Seite der Straße, der aufgelöst ist, und es sind acht Männer in diesem Raum. Und klar, nichts passiert, aber der andere Taxi-Fahrer wird aufgeholt, und es ist wie aus einem wirklich wütenden Film. Der Fahrer fährt, er fährt die Bremsen, und als er die Bremsen fährt, beginnt der Innenseite des Fahrers zu glösen, mit diesen großen bluen LEDs. Und es gibt Däden, wie ein Herz und ein Tettibär hängen in der Klappe, und es gibt Frieren um die Länge des Fahrers. Und auf der Front, wo der Windschildweiber-Fluid kommt, um die Fenster zu spüren, haben sie auch glückende LEDs. Und das ganze Auto glückt mit all diesen verschiedenen Lichtern. Ich denke, dass es nicht mehr das Kraftsystem für diese Lichter hat. Es hat alles aufgeschnitten, Schadkarpiteln auf der Inseite und alles. Das war mein Reisen, Mann. Ich habe versucht, in Irak zu reisen, um meine Freunde zu wissen, dass ich komme. Und sie wussten, dass ich, wenn ich kam, weil ich von einem Befehl in Istanbul ausfuhren wollte, aber ich konnte sie nicht nach dem Befehl erreichen, also wussten sie nicht, ob mein Flug landete, ob ich in einem Taxi war. Es war ein sehr langer Reisen, um die Bordere von Syrien, in der Türkei, in Irak. Es ist wie in Brasilien, da haben die Jungs, die fast wie Kornen auf der Straße sind, mit einer Plastik-Reflektivlinie auf der Kante. Wenn du ein Schusser oder so bist, musst du in zwischen die Plastik-Linie schießen, damit du weißt, wie du auf der Maske aufstehen kannst. Und dann stoppt das.
Ein Freund meines Erachtens hat in seinem Blog geschrieben, eine gute Art, eine Kultur und eine Gesellschaft zu finden, ist, die Kabelung zu schauen. Was ist die Situation in der Technologie?
Um dir eine Idee zu geben, der bördere Irakische Börde in Zakhau, hatten sie ein paar Windows-Maschinen, die sie in die Information entdecken. Ich versuchte, das zu schuldersurfen, aber es war nicht sehr effektiv. Sie haben den Monitor von mir entfernt. Aber sie hatten einfach alte Computer aus den 90ern. Aber die meisten Araben und Kurdischen, die ich kennengelernt habe, waren Ingenieure. Sie hatten Computer-Scienzen-Geräte, wie das Programm Windows 3.1 in dem 21. Die neuen Iraqi-Money, anstatt die Symbol der Akkult, wie die amerikanische Geld, wie die Piramidae, haben sie Mathematikformeln und die Leute, die mit dem Programm aufgenommen haben, und ihre Gesichter, die die Menschen der Wissenschaft erinnern. Aber das Kabel da, das ist eigentlich ganz interessant. Ich kann nicht sogar den Himmel sehen in einigen Fotos, aber es gibt so viele Kabel, elektrische Kabel und alles.
Und während deiner zweiten Sitzung auf diesem Irak-Experiment hast du viele Fotos gezeigt.
Ich lege alle meine Fotos auf Flickr oder auf Internet, andere Orte unter Creative Commons. Manche Leute haben mich nicht Kontakt gemacht, sie nehmen nur die Bilder.
Interessant.
Und dann habe ich auch alle Dinge geschrieben, die da waren, was dieses Stück Equipment war. Wir können einfach in den Wäldern online gehen, ein Feuerwerk haben, eine VoIP-Konnection haben, und in der Mitte des Wälders nur Telefonkolle machen. Ich glaube, dass ich der einzige Freund war, der ihn in Irak besucht hat.
Was war deine Impression von der Situation?
Aber eine der wichtigsten Dinge, die mir wichtig waren, war, dass ich die Leute, die ich mit Zeit verabschiedete, interviewte. Ist es etwas, was du an einen Irakischen Zivilisten fragen möchtest? Ist es etwas, was du an einen Sunni Arabischen Männern möchtest? Ist der Preis des Gas jetzt mehr teurer oder vor der Waffe? Sie haben es trotzdem doch beantwortet. Wie hat das dich beeindruckt? Oder ich wünsche mir, dass ich Kinder habe, bevor ich sterbe, diese Art von Sachen. Aber gleichzeitig sind sie auch sehr hilfreich und hoffnungsvoll und resilient. Und generell wollen sie einen besseren, lebenswahrbaren Ort machen. Es ist sehr intensiv, sich mit Menschen zu sitzen und mit ihnen zu reden, die in ihrem Land gezwungen sind. Die irakischen Menschen, mit denen ich Zeit hatte, können sich nicht von Irak verlassen, mit der Auszeichnung, dass sie in, ich denke, in einem Land in Süd-Easterner Asien sind, und ich denke, sie können in Syrien oder Jordan gehen. Sie können nicht aus dem Blutboden, das ihr Land ist, sogar wenn sie die Möglichkeit hatten, auszugehen, sind sie gezwungen, zu bleiben. Und wie wir in vielen Wahlen, wir lieben so, dass wir diese schlechten Dinge niemals lassen. Die nächste Zeit, wenn wir in der Karriere sind, gehen wir weiter. Natürlich ist das nicht der Fall. Und Irak ist nur ein Beispiel dieses Types der Unwahrheit. Es ist nicht unbedingt die gleiche Schale, aber es ist das gleiche Type der Unwahrheit.
Dann kam die Hurrikan-Saison in den Karibischen See, und dann hat die Katrina-Hurrikan in New Orleans gespielt, die weltweit gut über den Weltkampf verabschiedet wurde. Ich habe persönlich die News ziemlich intensiv verfolgt. Ich war auch auf deinem Blog, von damals haben wir hier und dann gesprochen. Was war das Speziale?
Aber sie mögen nicht Refugee sein, weil sie amerikanische Zivilisten sind.
Aber am Ende waren sie in diesem Sinne wie Refugee, im Sinne der restlichen amerikanischen Gesellschaft.
Es wäre sehr abhängig, diese Menschen zu nennen, einfach weil, wenn man sich die Handlung anschaut, und man sieht, wie sie umgebracht wurden, und man sieht, wie die Menschen sie verregen haben. Es gab auch viele Menschen, die sehr bitter waren und nicht wirklich interessiert waren, um zu helfen. Ich hatte jetzt ein bisschen Zeit, also habe ich eine Telefonnachrichtung von Shenni Jardin von Boing Boing gemacht. Ich habe ihr gesagt, hier ist eine Liste meiner Fähigkeiten. Ich habe ihr eine Liste meiner Fähigkeiten gesagt. Ich habe eine gute Verwaltung von meinem Job. Ich will irgendwie helfen, wie ich kann. Sie sagt mir, ich kenne jemanden, der Joel Johnson von Gizmodo ist. Wir hatten ein paar Stunden später ein paar Ad-hoc-Planen, in Houston zu treffen. Und etwa 48 Stunden später hatte ich ein Flugzeugticket, und nicht zu, ich glaube, am nächsten Montag. Das alles begann am Freitag, am nächsten Montag. Ich war in Houston, glaube ich, und ich war Joel Johnson am Flugzeugticket. Ich war mit Joel Johnson am Flugzeugticket und wir haben uns direkt mit den Indie-Media-Leuten in Houston gehalten. Wir haben mit einer localen Radio-Station, Austin Airwaves, gearbeitet, die in Houston reisen. Wir haben mit ihnen angefangen, Technologie zu bauen, die Infrastruktur zu sprechen, die sie brauchen, und ihnen zu helfen, alles zu finden, was sie brauchen. Sie machen viel mehr. Wenn ihr einen Radio-Transmitter bauen wollt, könnt ihr auf ihrem Website finden. Wenn ihr über legalen Probleme findet, könnt ihr mit ihnen sprechen. Sie sind die wirklich tollen Radio-Leute in den USA. Sie haben die FCC-Permisse für die Radio-Stationen gegründet. Als wir gesagt haben, wir könnten 10.000. Und er sagt, Frieden der Dialogie. Was meinst du? Was wäre es, wenn sie Rap-Musik hören würden? Du erzählst ihnen Informationen über Lieblingskinder, die verloren oder gefunden wurden, Informationen, die absolut nötig sind. Definitiv. Die Leute, die in der Astrodome leben, die in der Astrodome sitzen, in den Blechern, die sich in die Spielzeuge sehen, und in der Mitte der Blechern sind Bett nach Bett nach Bett nach Bett nach Bett, kein privates Raum, was auch immer.
Licht auf.
Wenn sie aus der Strecke gehen wollten, das ist ein perfekter Beispiel der wunderschönsten amerikanischen Atetude, die mich wirklich frustriert. Diese Leute verlieren ihr Haus, sie haben alles verloren, was sie haben, und sie sind in Houston, in einer Stadt, die wieder funktioniert. Ich glaube, jemand ist weggekommen, zum Strip-Club oder Bar. Ich bin nicht wirklich interessiert, in einem Strip-Club oder Bar zu gehen. Wenn jemand um 10 oder 20 Minuten um 9 oder 10 Uhr morgens war, ich vergesse genau, was die Zeit, die sie setzten, waren, dann, wenn sie die Familienwäsche kaufen würden, würden sie zurückgezogen werden, aber sonst würden sie enttäuscht werden. Aber ich denke vielleicht, dass das... Die Menschen werden von den Habitur und der Situation beigetragen. Wenn sie in die Dome kommen, haben sie die Sicherheit, dass sie sie runterzulassen, bevor sie in die Dome kommen. Sie konnten keine Waffen oder Kontrabann bringen. Diese Menschen, jede eine von ihnen, wurden in Effekt getraut. Sie hatten die Möglichkeit, zu gehen. Manchmal konnten sie zurückkommen, wenn es zu spät war und sie etwas Unmögliches gemacht haben. Ich sage Unmögliches, aber in Kalifornien gibt es da Fingerquotes. Sie haben sich alle Fragen gestellt. Das ist derjenige, der einfach zurückkehren will, damit er nach Hause geht. Diese Situation ist für mich einfach beeindruckend. Es war ein Zeitpunkt, als ich dir bereits gesagt habe.
Dass ich dich damals in Insta-Messagen kontaktiert habe. Ein paar Tage später warst du direkt aus Houston nach New Orleans.
Es gab ein paar Dinge. Ich habe zu meinem Ex-Fiancé gesagt, dass ich in New Orleans nicht gehen würde. Und ich dachte damals nicht, dass ich in New Orleans gehen würde. Die Leute, die ich in Houston arbeitete, hatten viele andere Dinge, die sie machen sollten. Was dann eigentlich passiert ist, es war ein Tiefend mit den Bürokraten in Houston. Nachdem wir in New Orleans waren, hat es sich aufgebaut. Es war ein paar Tage aufgebaut. Und nach ein paar Tagen, hat es alle Leute, alle verbreiteten Menschen, oder Refinierenden, die abgeliefert wurden, weil es ein Sport-Spiel im Stadion gewesen wäre. Und ich habe einfach aus dem Blut einen Telefon von jemandem in New Orleans, den ich vorher schon mitgearbeitet habe, und er sagte, wir brauchen jemanden, der uns das Internet bringt. Wir brauchen jemanden, der uns das Internet bringt, wir brauchen Computern, wir brauchen technische Hilfe, wir brauchen ein Kommunikations-Team. Jake, kannst du einen Kommunikations-Team unterbrechen? AMD hat eigentlich ein paar seltsame, verbauten Windows-Device gesucht, die wir nicht viel Zeit hatten, um Linux aufzulegen, weil wir andere Dinge beschäftigt haben. Eine sehr wichtige Sache, bevor wir in eine Schadenszone gehen. Aber bevor wir in New Orleans gingen, wollten wir in Baton Rouge stoppen, um an dem Ort zu bleiben, um die Checkpoints und die Kurven zu bekommen. Aber wir mussten auch unsere eigenen Futter und Wasser kaufen, wir brauchten Gas und wir hatten, oh, ich weiß nicht, 100 Dollar für einen Red Bull.
Baton Rouge, ist das nicht die Kapitel der Region? Aber es war die temporäre Kapitel, weil alles aus New Orleans ausgeruht wurde, mit dem Meister, die in Baton Rouge kam.
Wir hatten Gas, Red Bull, Blankete, einige AMD-Computer, EVDO-Equipment, andere Laptop, Radio-Scanner, Telefon-Line-Equipment, Telefone, Tonnen 802.11B-Geräte, Blank-CDs, alles was wir mit uns bringen könnten, um die Arbeit zu machen. Wir haben den Wifi von seinem Mac mit EVDO gespart, und als wir da waren, waren alle Journalisten, die wir kennengelernt haben, wie die von der GNN, der Grilla News Network, die von anderen europäischen Journalisten, die dort in New Orleans waren, alle haben Internet-Axis, wie wir vorher nicht hatten. Die EVDO ist nicht besonders schnell, es ist wie eine Dual-Channel-ISDN-Speed, aber das ist so viel schneller als keine Internet, aber es war wirklich großartig. Und dann über Wifi zu teilen, war nicht schlecht, so lange als viele Leute nicht viele sendeten.
So, war EVDO ein System, das vorher dort arbeitete, oder wurde dann nach der Katastrophe geplant?
Aber es war so, dass die EVDO-Infrastruktur die Hurricane Katrina entgegen überlebt.
Sind ihr direkt in die Flotte in New Orleans? Man kann die Levis sehen, wo sie brechen. Und der Verlust war total eindeutig. Das ist eine interessante Erfahrung, die ich an der anderen Seite des Atlantikens hatte. Sie sind sehr beschäftigt mit Publisieren von Fernsehern. Und alles, was online war, war interessant. Sie entkodierten es sofort, sowohl in Windows-Media als auch im QuickTime-Format. Es war toll, also habe ich einen real-time, gefilterten Stream von Medien, den ich in diesem Event reportiere. Ich habe also auf dem gleichen Niveau von Informationen, wie wahrscheinlich alle in den USA, natürlich nicht so viel, aber ich war ziemlich nahe.
Es ist auch die Sektion von New Orleans, die sehr einfach zu finden war. Es gab fünf verschiedene Straßen, die du in die Stadt gehen könntest, damit du dich nicht über militärische Checkpoints verabschieden musstest, was man, so lange du vor der Kurfhür reist, in Algerien gehen konnte. Wo gehst du denn hin? Als ich in die Stadt mit anderen Journalisten in die Stadt ging, bin ich in die französische Quartier und bin auch gerade umgekehrt. Wir sind in den unteren neunsten Bereichen, um in die verschiedenen Orte zu gehen. Aber es war einfach absolut erstaunlich für mich. Was so zerstört war, war nicht nur das Hurrikan, sondern auch das Nachdenken des Hurrikans, sondern auch die Menschen, wie sie sich mit dem Hurrikan befinden, und die Antwort auf das Hurrikan, und was dann passiert ist, nach diesem Verlust, und der menschliche Verlust, der sich in der Natur ausgeschlossen hat, ist das ein ganz krasser Verlust. Und so, wenn du durch die Stadt geht, sind es sicherlich die Flüsse, die Haare, die verbrannt werden, die Türen, die fallen, und alles ist ein absoluter Schmuck. Es ist wie wenn du in ein wirklich schlechtes Sci-Fi-Zombie-Film oder so reist, und es gibt bestimmte Teile der Stadt, die auf den Türen D-Mort-Kodes hatten, andere Teile der Stadt, die D-Mort-Kodes nicht hatten, und dann siehst du ein Licht auf.
Was sind diese D-Mort-Kodes?
Eine D-Mort-Kode ist das Femme-Diesaster-Management-Mortuier-Team. Ich vergesse genau, was das Akronym ist, aber es ist ein X, und in jeder einzelnen Quadrate, also vier Quadranten, hast du das untere Quadrat von X, das dir sagt, wie viele sterbende Bodies, oder wie viele live Bodies, oder wie viele Menschen, wenn das Ding gesucht wurde. Wenn du eine Linie hast, bedeutet das, dass jemand in dem Gebäude ist. Das ist unsere offizielle US-Presse-Karte, und die Polizei steht vor unseren Fenstern und sagt, das ist nicht für dich zu sehen. Und es ist überall, es war ähnlich wie in Houston. Ich habe einen polischen Presseagent kennengelernt, der wieder eine House of Representatives ID-Karte hat. Er sagte, das Sensoren hier ist toll, das erinnert mich an, wie es in Polen war, um die USSR zu verhandeln, das war einfach verrückt. Und so, wieder, in New Orleans war es sehr konsistent, um die schlechte Nachricht zu verheiden. Das Fakt, dass sieben älterliche Menschen in einem Nursing-Holm sterben, ist nicht wirklich so aus der Hand, wenn man sich an die Skala dieses Verlusts denkt. Und es war wunderschön für mich, denn das ist die exakt andere Ansicht, die ich nehmen möchte. Etwas Schöneres ist passiert, diese Tragedie hat diese Menschen verfallt, und wir wollen nicht, dass sie ihre Erinnerung nicht verschwinden, dass sie so unnötig sterben würden, und wenn sie so unnötig sterben würden, wollten die Polizei sie nicht zeigen, und natürlich haben sie es verfallt, und alle sahen diese Fotos. Aber das schlichte Fakt ist, dass es irgendwie zu schicken ist, es würde die Schande der Fähigkeit des US-Gesetzes und der natürlichen Verlust nehmen, die keiner für sich verantwortlich war. Und das, viele von diesen Leuten haben versucht, das alles zu passieren.
Du bist in Algeria gekommen und hast diesen Jungen, was ist der Name wieder? Ja, der islamische Aktivist. Kannst du etwas über ihn sagen? Er war ein sehr beeindruckender Mann, was ich gesehen habe.
Und das ist das Südland von Amerika. Es ist nicht so anders, racialen Tensionen zu haben, aber die racialen Tensionen waren auf einem ganz neuen Niveau. Die Menschen waren definitiv viel more violent. Und das ist wieder eine Region von New Orleans, die nicht flodiert. Diese Fragen haben natürlich auch nicht Schuhe, die am Boden seiner Füße nicht dünn waren. Aber es gab Leute in dieser Nachbarschaft, die. Malik Rahim hat die Leute aus der Nachbarschaft zusammengebracht. Er hat die Futter verabschiedet, er hat die Medizin geholfen, er hat eine Medikamentur zusammengelegt, er hat anrufen lassen und mehr Leute in die Nachbarschaft gebracht. Das ist dann, wie er mich und Joel in die Nachbarschaft gebracht hat. Und es war durch das organisieren von radikalen Grasen, dass er sich also die Serien von Gewalt beenden konnte. Er konnte die Gemeinde organisieren, um die Nachbarn zu berichten, wenn solche Dinge anfangen. Er konnte Medizin, die Menschen aus allen USA bringen, wenn sie kommen mussten. Und es war grundsätzlich wegen dieses Mannes, der sein Haus ausgeliefert hat und sein Nachbar sein Haus ausgeliefert hat. Diese Gemeinschaft wäre ein verletzter Wasteland gewesen. Das ist nicht wirklich... Ich kenne keine Autos, also ist das kein großes Problem. Aber diese Leute sind auch sehr krank. Keine Bus kam für sie, um sie zu evakuieren, und ihr Mann hatte Gängerein in seinen Beinen. Die älteren Leute.
Und in der Ende, sie haben wahrscheinlich, manche von ihnen haben nicht glaubt, was sie gesagt haben, dass alles zerstört werden wird.
Also, ich meine, viele dieser Menschen, auch sie wussten nicht, was los war. Als ich in New Orleans nach Hause ging, stand ich auf einem Flugzeug. Ich habe nie in meinem ganzen Leben einen Erstklass verflogen, und nach dieser Erfahrung denke ich nicht, dass ich noch mal neben jemandem im Erstklass sitzen möchte. Ich habe es auf der Televise gehört, der Herr war die Busse für alle, die nicht einen Weg auslösen wollen, die Ende ist nah, und so weiter. In diesem Flugzeug ist es ein der letzten Flugzeuge, das New Orleans verlassen wird, bevor der nächste Schuss aufhört. Diese Leute haben keine Televise. Als wir mit Essen, Wasser, Computern und Internetabkommen hergebracht haben, waren wir die ersten Leute in der Region, die für die meisten der Leute in dieser Region die ersten Computer in der Welt hatten. Die Leute, die für FEMA registriert haben, die nie ein Keyboard in ihrem Leben touchten. Ich bekomme viele Responses, wenn ich darüber rede. Sie haben mich eingeladen, ein Keynote-Speaker zu sein. Sie wurden von einem tollen Jungen und Jungen. Für mich ist das eine seltsame. Viele Leute haben gesagt, dass sie sehr traurig waren, aber dann sehen sie jemanden, der ein schmerzhafter, unheiliger Mensch auf der Straße ist, und dann nicht wechseln, wenn es Schnee auf ihnen fällt, und sie kalt und sterben. Wie kann ich einen Unterschied in der Welt machen? Das ist mein Wille, das ist, was ich tue. Ich saß da und sprach mit ein paar Leuten über das, was sie tun. Einige Leute haben mich für Advice und Fahrt in 3. Wie beherrschst du diese Situation? Ich bin persönlich über die Faktoren, dass Menschen sich um sich kümmern können. In meiner Erfahrung sieht es aus, dass viele Leute nicht um sich kümmern.
Jeder hat sich etwas mehr Zeit genommen, bevor er aufstehen und gehen konnte. Das war sehr interessant zu sehen. Auch wenn dieses Event so viel Dinge gibt, viele interessante Dinge, die dich in den nächsten Moment bewegen. Ich denke, wir sind nicht mehr am Ende dieses Interviews. Ich möchte dich wieder über die gesamte Erfahrung im Kongress fragen, was du in den letzten Wochen in der Region gesehen hast.
Ich glaube, das ist die beste Konferenz, in der ich je gewesen bin. Es war nur ein paar Läden vor allem, was ich vorher erlebt habe. Manuel Goldstein's Hope ist eine wirklich solide Konferenz. Die nächsten fünf Minuten sind auch sehr schön. Es gibt auch viel Diskussion über Medien und Politik, mit einigen Technologien, wie 2600s Hope. Technologie mit einigen Politikien, und Chaos-Kommunikationskongress ist großartig, weil es die nächsten fünf Minuten, die Hope und die Defcon mir in der europäischen Stadt alles zusammengelegt hat. 10 Gigabit Uplink mit echten IP-Adressen, mit der Klasse B, das war toll. Es war absolut... Ich meine, du siehst das nicht sogar an anderen Konferenzen.
Und danke dir sehr für dieses sehr intensive, sehr persönliche Interview, das ist jetzt das letzte Interview, das Konkurs ist jetzt vorbei. Ich bin sehr glücklich, wie alles funktioniert, insbesondere über den Widerstand und alle Reaktionen.